Now let's discuss another
symmetric encryption algorithm,
the advanced encryption standard,
or AES.
Recall that a major
shortcoming of DES is that
the key length is only 56 bit, and
that is considered to be short.
In other words, the key space is
relatively small, and an attacker
can use brute force to find the key
using the power of today's computers.
Of course, we can use [INAUDIBLE]
to increase the key length, but
that would mean running DES three times,
and
that's not the most efficient
way of doing encryption.
Therefore, there was a need for
a new encryption algorithm that can take
longer key length, but
also be efficient.
So in 1997,
NIST put out a public call for
a new encryption
standard to replace DES.
After a few rounds of submissions and
reviews, AES was finalized, and
it became a new standard, replacing DES.
Like DES, AES is also a block cipher,
whereas in DES,
the input plaintext block is 64 bit,
in AES it is 128 bit.
In DES the key length is only 56 bit.
In AES it can be 128, 192, or 256 bits.
These key lengths are considered long
enough to defeat brute force
attempt to search for a key.
Here is a high level view of AES.
The encryption process is as follows.
Again, the plaintext block is
represented as a square matrix.
We call it a state array, and
we first XOR with the key.
Again, the key is also
represented as a square matrix.
Then the state arrays go through
multiple rounds of encryption.
At each round, it goes through several
operations that represent substitution
and permutation, and also the round
key is XOR to this state array.
The operations at each round
include substitute bytes.
This involves using a table
referred to as a S box to perform
byte to byte substitution of the block.
Shift rows is a simple permutation
that is performed row by row.
Mixed columns is a substitution
that alters each byte in a column
as a function of all
the bytes in the column.
And then the result is
XOR in a round key.
The operations of the last round
includes substitute bytes,
shift rows and add round key,
and the result is a cipher text.
In AES, the decryption process runs
the algorithm in the reverse direction.
This means that each of these
operations must be reversible.
Let's take a look.
Now, adding round key
involves the XOR operation.
An XOR operation by
itself is reversible.
The other operations, meaning
substitute bytes, shift rows, and
mix columns, an inverse function
is used in a decryption algorithm.
By using this inverse function,
we can reverse
the action of substitute bytes that
was performed in the encryption.
Likewise, we can reverse
the effects of shift rows and
mix columns in the decryption process.
Therefore, each of
the operations are reversible.
As a result, when we run
the algorithm in the reverse order,
we can decrypt the cipher
text back into the plaintext.